SEEMS TO MAKE A LOT OF SENSE.
TUESDAY’S PRIMARY STILL ON
DESPITE SOME STATES POSTPONING
THEM.
GOVERNOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I’M SURE YOU’RE SYMPATHETIC WITH
THE PROBLEMS OF THE NEW YORK
GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW TRYING TO
DEAL WITH ITS FIRST DEATH.
ARE GOVERNORS WORKING TOGETHER,
SHARE PLAN THAT IS THEY HAVE
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
AVAILABILITY NOW THAT WE WILL
SEE COMING THIS WEEK OF THOSE
TESTS?
>> WELL, NO, ABSOLUTELY, WE ARE
SHARING INFORMATION AND WE ARE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
IN FACT, WE GOT A WAIVER
YESTERDAY WE ARE HAPPY ABOUT IN
REGARD TO WE CLOSE OUR SCHOOLS
AS YOU REPORTED.
NOW THE CONCERN IS HOW DO YOU
GET FOOD OUT TO KIDS.
THEY GAVE US A SPECIFIC WAIVER
TO PACKAGE THE FOOD AND TAKE IT
OUT.
IT’S UP TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT HOW TO DO IT, BUT THEY
WERE VERY FAST, WITHIN WITHIN 2
HOURS, LESS THAN THAT AND GOT
SUPPLIES, NOTIFICATION OF
SUPPLIES COMING IN.
LOOK, EVERYBODY IS IN THIS
TOGETHER AND WE ARE SHARING
INFORMATION AND WE ARE SHARING
WITH FELLOW GOVERNORS.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS -- WE ALL GOT
THE SAME CHALLENGE.
DAVID: WE DO.
WE DO.
WE GOT TO COME TOGETHER IN A
SIMILAR WAY.
WE WILL GET CLEAR NUMBERS OF HOW
MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN INFECTED.
YOUR DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH HEAD
AMY ATKINS SAID THIS WEEK THAT,
IN FACT, A HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE ARE CARRYING THE VIRUS IN
THE STATE OF OHIO, THAT’S
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH FIGURE.
DO YOU STANDBY HER FIGURE?
>> WELL, WE -- WHAT SHE SAID IS
THAT SOME MODELING WOULD SHOW AT
THIS POINT THAT THAT’S WHAT WE
HAVE SPREAD AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN OHIO THAT HAVE THAT.
LAST NIGHT I SHUT CASINOS, WE
ARE TALKING TO PEOPLE IN REGARD
TO DAY CARE AND IF YOU CAN TAKE
YOUR CHILD TO TAKE THEM OUT AND
THERE’S WAYS TO SEGMENT
DIFFERENT GROUPS, THAT’S
CERTAINLY A WAY TO DO IT.
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT VOTING, WE
HAVE BEEN VOTING IN OHIO SINCE
FEBRUARY 19TH, WE CONTINUE TO
VOTE, POLLS ARE OPEN FOR ANYBODY
WATCHING FROM OHIO, POLLS ARE
OPEN TODAY, THEY ARE OPEN SUNDAY
AND MONDAY AND TUESDAY IS 13
HOURS, 6:30 IN THE MORNING TO
7:30 AT NIGHT.
THEY’RE OPEN AND WE DID MOVE
POLLING PLACES, WE MOVED OUT OF
NURSING HOMES.
THAT MADE NO SENSE AND ALSO
SCHOOLS WERE CLOSED SO SO THAT
WE ARE NOT MIXING ON TUESDAY, WE
ARE NOT MIXING PEOPLE WITH THE
KIDS AND VICE VERSA AND WE ARE
TAKING DRAMATIC ACTIONS.
DAVID: LET’S HOPE THAT TESTING
SHOW IT IS NOT AS HIGH.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE NUMBERS FOR
THE UNITED STATESES IS -- AS A W
WOULD BE EXTRAORDINARILY -- REAL
QUICK, SIR.
>> NO, I JUST WANT TO SAY I
THINK THE KEY HERE IS THOUGH,
EXPERTS WHO HAVE LOOKED AT THIS
AND MODELED THIS THAT WITHOUT
INTERVENTION, WITHOUT US DOING
THOSE THINGS WE WOULD EXPECT IN
THIS COUNTRY TO HAVE 40 TO 70%
OF THE POPULATION EVENTUALLY GET
THIS.
SO WE ARE TRYING TO TAKE THE
NUMBERS DOWN AND THAT’S --
THAT’S WHY WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
BIG NUMBERS BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE LOOKING AT.
DAVID: WELL, GOVERNOR, WE WISH
YOU THE VERY BEST, YOU AND THE
PEOPLE OF OHIO, VERY NEAR AND
DEAR TO OUR HEARTS AND WE ARE
PRAYING FOR YOU, THANK YOU VERY